Olá hoje nós vamos testar pata de
galinha com Mel chinês Olha aí do Naruto
barata foi lá e eu tenho aqui coisas
fora preparar eu vou provar este tempo
comidas mais estranhas que eu encontrei
negócio pode
levar aqui
mais eu hoje trago-vos aqui uma prova de
gastronomia chinesa se
alimentar só porque isso não parece nada
bom isto não dá para ver o que é porque
não tem nada aqui não é nada escrito é
tudo chinês não dá para perceber nada
ele como parece que parecem espadas de
soja eu tô inventar né eu tô inventado
Não faço ideia o ovo cozido
é todo mundo mas o principal pessoal ó
o papa de galinha frita com Mel do
espada na churrasqueira nem sei o que
estudo é parte da linha com unha com
podem ver bom riscar a minha vida hoje
pessoal então já deixa eu posso morrer
like aqui nesse vídeo eu comentei
embaixo fala que ter a nota que eu vou
dar essa parte de galinha de 0 a 10
comentem aí e no final a vou dizer a
nossa ok efe adivinhar ganha uma
torradeira eu mando para vossa casa
agora puxei tela para cima eu vou morrer
Neste vídeo né
eu vou assim ó a espécie foi lá começar
por esta espetada pessoal outro super
curioso para saber o que é que isto é
que eu tô com receio fica algumas coisas
eu acho que são fora do prazo esta não
disse data de validade sequer quando é
que isto foi feito em 2001 e
G1
a
embalagem deve estar ansiosa para
apanhar a ficar ligando toda sugaram o
estilo tudo esmagado a pra neste sábado
nem tudo junto Olha isso vem com olho
bem estranho OK
e isto cheira tão mal não desculpa lá
vamos lá provar isto não acontece na
terra
cheirasse sapato do quem sobe a montanha
a 7 dias sabem que ele chulé Porque
mexer agora três não vai a uma campanha
dentro da aplicação Calma
isso é bom pessoal
é duro e
E aí
a figura de dinossauro
Aqui estamos ficar pa
não consigo eu não consigo comer isso
que é que isto é
ai isso é muito pequena aí ó E aí
[Música]
o pai filha da
e
O Rappa preta no palco e
eu não sei o que isto é eu não vou
construindo não sabe
eu só sei que é muito picante Isso não
funciona nada mexer muito tempo pa
interessado 10 não funciona o teste de
doces vem lá perto é isso é horrível
partir desta mesa próximo produto fala o
nosso ovo cozido não sei mas isto parece
estar fora do prazo certo do mundo 2021
e se prover de Janeiro eu estou fosse
tudo para as em janeiro o que eu faço
por vocês e Janeiro
estou supostamente é pré-cozido e
a textura horrível no isto parece uma
pedra
não é o que é novas Possibilidade é o
uso de borracha é uma das jóias do
thanos um
G1
eu moro em 3 dias não vai lá
e me fala
não procurassem parte está muito duro né
o
irmão você tipo batata sabem amor você
instalar isso está bom
E aí
e
não é mal
fora do prazo até bem melhor eu não
consigo eu não eu não vou conseguir
e olha lá em cima e
é
[Música]
que eu não consigo nestas coisas pa nada
contra a gastronomia chinesa Ok mas eu
não consigo não dar espera 10 a 0 também
não Vado um porque minimamente sabe a
soja Ok
pizza calabresa pergunta que uma
salsicha vamos analisar esta embalagem
mais Eclipse
salsichas da Larissa picantes essa tem
data de validade
2021 seis do oito eu comprei de tudo
fora do prazo é isso não não sabe não
sabe porque já pronta É isso
mesmo não
apresente da minha salsicha vamos lá
para várias pessoal
eu vou tentar aqui no meio porque aqui
tem é só tenho Malagueta aqui em tema de
notas perfeitamente a
olá
olá olá
ah
[Música]
meu Deus diga só assim tão sensível ela
picantes esqueçam a salsicha o sabor é
bom ok é a textura um pouco estranha mas
é muito picante dela dessa de 14 próximo
produto
O que vem a ser isto acho que estão tipo
até em inglês aqui
Brides
Week Norte
o biquinho acho que foi assim ser alga
alga seca
atendimento sempre alga seca alegar tem
51 de 2022 Ok é só posso comer em
segurança Não faço ideia de como é que
eles comem só mas eu acho que isso é
para meter na água tanto que eu já
trouxe aqui um pote
[Música]
quero maravilhoso e
E aí
é
realmente cheira cheira algas é isso
isso tem bastante Sao Domingos Sao mesmo
e não dá para comer e com certeza para
fazer com água antes de cozinhar tem que
deixar em água por 20 30 minutos acho
que é tipo bacalhau neste tem que deixar
a água primeiro que aparecer o sal
fritar ou cozinhar na sopa
a água quente Bora lá preparar as nossas
aulas uma
duas três quatro cinco seis sete acho
que é por cento e ela já começa a
borbulhar já ficou bem mais macia também
trouxe já pode comer não é o que é que
vocês acham essa Pequena já tá bem
melhorzinha né
é
muito bom curso é bom estou em dúvida
eu estou muito bom
pela de sal mas na própria embalagem só
me diziam que eu tinha de colocar em
Água primeiro 20 minutos então eu vou
deixar passar a questão do sal mas fora
o sol está muito bom pessoal tá mesmo
muito estas algas eu vou dar um oito em
dez tá Bora lá o que interessa pessoal
passa de galinha que se como é que é
isto que quem é que inventou esse treco
pai eu vou começar por esse produto que
me parece ser menos caótico falar me só
que nessas Patinhas temos 63 por cento
do sódio recomendado diariamente muito
bem vamos para o elevadíssimo e
e a tem várias dentro que eu pensei que
fosse só uma
você não chegou cheiro obviamente está
em vácuo também né isso tem tudo
apertado
e cheguei bem já tem uma coisa gelatina
e
E aí é isso
é uma pata de galinha uma asa de galinha
gelatina
está Platina pura meu que horror ai
desgraçado o animal reparem só como ela
é gelatinosa agora 32 não vai
isso é muito estranho pa a minha língua
ficou aqui já rejeitou
e com isto é
E aí
da manhã assiste em uma pata Isto é a
pata fossilizada em gelatina agora que
eu percebi que eu
não faz isso o bicho pa
isso é horrível mais uma vez digo nada
contra a sua gastronomia Mas eu não
estou habituado isto não prefiro arroz
com feijão e o de 0 a 10 eu dou um
sistema muito mal eu dou um só porque
tem assim um toque de leva a soja também
e assalto em assim aquele toque asiático
Bora lá para o próximo Pessoal agora é o
brigadeiro uma das mais já deixou o
vosso lá e que aqui neste vídeo pessoal
até porque eu vou comer uma pata de
galinha gigante cristalizado em mel tu
ainda tem aquele resto do outro e deixar
de postar vídeos definitivamente Ok já
sabe o que aconteceu porque vamos lá
comer a parte da linha Suprema pessoal
Abrir ficou muito cuidado porque eu não
sei
e tem vários também ok ok ok Vem três já
agora só passar lá no Tik Tok está
embaixo também não é descrição eu vou
talvez dar estão os amigos meus essas
Patinhas restantes Ok vamos ver a
criação eles por lá não sei é só seguir
em beijo
e
São Paulo vamos ver
isto é inacreditável ela vem mesmo como
está na imagem
color aqui um dedo olha só ai galinha ou
não ela vem com de destruído
E aí
e
hoje Vamos provar
esta beleza Ou se vocês não deixarem
muito like aqui neste vídeo eu juro eu
juro que eu não grava mais vídeos meu
vocês tem que deixar like porque eu vou
comer isto por vocês
é isso que vai dentro da embalagem vamos
começar pelo vendo eu vou chupar o dedo
E aí
e
é picantes
até o outro é combustível como é que eu
faço um dos Bichos e gelatina pa
começaram que o ácido Branco deve Pelo
menos foi até de curas que morrer vamos
lá provar a parte então eu vou aqui já
trincar o grosso dela sabem aqui no meio
ó
é
possível comer isto Olha já era que é
aquilo é impossível como é
possível que eu canal pessoal impossível
eu estou a tentar ao máximo mas o cheiro
sabor a textura a viscosidade não deixa
brincar engolir não deixa eu tentar
entender eu gostava de conseguir engolir
isso mas eu não consigo esquecer
completamente horrível eu vou chamar a
minha namorada para ela experimentar
este vamos ver se ela consegue pelo
menos tentar duvido e isso senta senta
senta ok muito mal
sim ok 321
o
[Música]
Mastercard Não vou não não
faz aqui isto é uma pata de galinha olha
como é que está assim
eu
sou madrinha porque só uma lentidão
nível
e não olha
E aí
e
não não
deixa seu like para ela dar uma trinca
vai lá agora ela está à espera que vai
embora deixa seu like this
há 30 Tu conhece isso olha aquela comer
não isso não está comigo
não não
não é
o
espaço não gostei não
gostasse Como diz que não é sintomático
que é bom não estava à espera do Pior
estava À Espera de um epílogo aqui então
vamos assim maior Eu já comi a pele e
e
não
que é que foi
latinas
Muito obrigado
[Música]
aí no início do vídeo Qual era a
situação que eu ia dar aqui para esta
marca de galinha e a minha avaliação
para esta partida é zero infelizmente é
zero eu não consegui achar um sabor aqui
quer Isto é tudo gelatinoso a outra um
pouco melhor porque sabe mais a soja
tipo tem aquele molhinho né que elas
Latina meu mas esta
tem minha
unha indescritível isto 12 0 só quem
comentou usar galho uma torradeira a
nossa casa vou trocar a pilhas
totalmente financiada por mim nem Só
espero que tenham gostado quiser ver
mais vídeos como este aqui com produtos
asiáticos o outro produto qualquer a mãe
não ficar lá aquelas aquelas comidas
russas vindas lá da América está
qualquer comida assim estranha comenta
embaixo pessoalmente Pessoal espero que
tenham gostado já tá vendo esse muito
leite fica meio da Brasil mas enfim o a
vossa mãe pessoal só para tinha eu ligo
para ela e manda ela também e diga o que
querem ir para o almoço só para ver a
reação dela envie